un jour de juin 1986 arrêté dans la
maison avec les parents les frères et
soeurs pleuvait très fort à l'époque les
saisons de pluie était très rageuse et
puis mon monde s'écroulait la lumière du
jour est devenu progressivement noir je
n'ai plus rien vu quand je me suis quand
j'ai ouvert les yeux j'étais couché de
tout mon long sur le sol avec du sang
qui coulait sur mon avant bras
je venais de m'évanouir et en tombant
j'ai donc voté le mieux et il ya eu
cette blessure
quand je vois les yeux j'avais mon père
accroupi en train de m'appeler
j'entendais mon nom et je m'étais
évanoui
parce que ça faisait le quatrième jour
que mon estomac frêle n'avait pas mangé
je mettais évalue de faim et je me suis
réveillé mon père était paniqué
misérable parmi les misérables
nous sommes d'aller à la pharmacie pour
voir s'ils pouvaient quelque chose j'ai
été marqué par quelque chose qui ne me
quittera jamais fallait acheter quelques
petits médicaments ça coûte et 1500
francs de l'époque les a vu mon père
pour une fois disputé dans la pharmacie
ou demander qu'on puisse diminuer le
prix de ces médicaments
et comme c'est une pharmacie tapas bar
cagnois sous là bas
et il a demandé s'il pouvait voir un
comprimé de la plaquette pour pouvoir
aider son fils et ce sont les souvenirs
qui vous marquent à jamais dans tout
leur parcours de vie
je m'appelle vincent tôt billet je suis
le préfet d'abidjan
et si vous voulez tous les titres pour
éviter la confusion je suis préfet hors
grade de fédérer région préfet du
département d'abidjan
lalouch âge de conclure cette série de
présentations pas un parent ciconstances
pas un hasard mais que je fonctionne
être un complot les organisateurs ont
décidé de mettre à la fin au moment où
vous êtes fatigués et que vous avez trop
entendu que vous avez été ému et donc
j'ai la responsabilité d'entretenir les
quinze minutes qui viennent ce casque on
sort de cette salle est pas un concours
de hasards et il y est remplacé ensemble
et ça fait beaucoup pour vous
[Applaudissements]
et pendant le concours et hazard je
devrais parler devant une jeune pdg
à 39 ans je veux parler devant jeunes
administrateurs dans les grands cabinets
présidentiels avaient fait des dossiers
nationaux et internationaux
qui plus est le maire du territoire nous
trouvons pendant qu'au coup de hasard
par une femme qui aime parler de sa
diarrhée à la télévision et comme par
hasard il ya pas de hasard dans la vie
seulement il y est j'ai reçu un courrier
monsieur le préfet je ne souhaiterais
vous rencontrer pour les malades de
l'intestin
comme par hasard hier vendredi j'ai
décidé de leur souffrance la semaine
prochaine sans savoir que celui-ci n'est
ce pas vraiment avec un courrier n'est
ce pas quand on voit un courrier je sais
même pas qui nous et y est et on l'a
fait une imputation le chef de cabinet
vous appeler parce que j'ai reçu le
courrier comme par hasard y est
et comme par hasard il ya un militaire
dont vous savez qu'un préfet il a
certainement présentés dont une bonne
partie de représenter sécurité qui est
en même temps président parle quand même
d'un ami de fou mais pour moi c'est
compliqué parce que vous savez que dans
d'autres organisations associatives
le préfet le président de gestion de
tous les hôpitaux d'abidjan et donc je
suis le président du conseil de gestion
de l'hôpital s'il ya plus de ma vie dont
je suis le président des amis de fous je
me trouve devant un baril à 40 ans qui
se trouve en chine pour des séjours par
un concours de hasards
j'ai une dame qui donnent vie à la
poupée à caen bandai ventoux et bien sûr
je ma soeur je peux parler parce que
nous on se rencontre le marché gouro
d'adjamé
c'est ce que nous on s'est fait vendre
bgi negombo pas à qui n'est pas vraiment
un hasard
je comprends pourquoi depuis quelques
jours robert brazza de lui et moi on a
une amitié soudaine et rapide
je mets dans 700 je viens de comprendre
je pensais ça parce que je m'appelle
vincent et qu'il a un frère vincent nous
sommes rencontrés par hasard il
connaissait toute ma vie et depuis ce
jour tous les jours ils m'envoient des
messages qui soit à paris ou à abidjan
et c'est dans cette salle que j'ai
compris pourquoi cette amitié était
habituellement de triel dont j'ai la
responsabilité de conduire deux
concluent ces débats je voudrais arriver
sur mon enfance revenu sur mon enfance
je disais que dans mon dans mes
attributions et les bonnes parties de
sécurité et vous aimez ça je vous voyez
le lieutenant-colonel dans cette vie
d'apparat les joues sur la neige ou
l'indépendance où nous voyait dans le
clan costumes compte tenue d'apparat
avec des canons partout et vous rêvez
mais ça vous que therrien s'est tenue
d'apparat ya de quoi chu du corps des
blessures des difficultés d'enfance des
rudiments
est ce que vous savez que des restes
tenue d'apparat que vous voyez que vous
enviez il y à toutes les bêtises qui ont
été faites
les maraudes âge les petits petits coups
bas dans la maison les petits métiers
des échecs
est ce que vous savez que derrière cet
habillage ses voitures aux vitres
blindées
il ya toute la souffrance qui a été
subie pour arriver là tous les échecs et
des moments de total où on a pensé à
arrêter toute notre vie vous faites
autre chose
notre en france était difficile et long
c'est ce qu'on appelle les vautours
procédé pour tous nous étions des
vautours et pour se moquer de nous
enliser des vautours heures élèves
autour pour ce que cette année qui ont
la cinquantaine ici ce sont ceux qui
allaient manger les restes d'un repas
dans les internats quand les élèves - à
l'internât et reste qu'on ramasse sur la
table damas qui vont manger cela
s'appelle les vautours heures
nous on était vautours heures et ont
mangé ces réserves est pas et se sont
pas des limites parcellaires témoins
cela veut dire il ya beaucoup de gaza
aujourd'hui parce que un hasard qui m'a
me rappelle ce souvenir c'est quelqu'un
que je venais de rencontrer à tout
hasard devant l'hôtel et qui m'a montré
la photo quand j'étais aux cpe qui avec
moi maintenant où nous faisions tout
c'est tout ce parcours difficile la vie
est un peu plus compliqué que ce qu'on
voit la vie un peu plus compliqué que ce
qu'on le désire on regarde qui nous
sommes dues bill c'est plus compliqué
que tout ce que vous avez comme fanta 38
de réalisation et mon parcours comme
tout le monde l'a expliqué ici a été
difficile tout aussi difficile mon
parcours a commencé comme je vous
expliquais et j'ai fait un lycée des
campagnes de colt mais public et ppc et
pépé sera dispo aujourd'hui vous avez
tous vos enfants aujourd'hui dans les
écoles privées on a fait et pépé avec
les institutions des tuteurs de gros de
grosbois
il avait des pouvoirs s'appelait piment
à la qui s'appelait caïman vous
n'échappez pas soit le piment sur le
caïman mais c'est un coup le bois qui va
me frapper
on a fait des et pépé et on avance et
comme il fallait et avec des cas qui
comporte usé par un tournoi en est un
moment où vous êtes tellement assis sur
le cac et qui devient ici si vous
assurer tout ça va déchirer avec
délicatesse
vous marchez avec sobriété avec élégance
mais la finalité c'est de ne pas
déchirer le cas qu'il est donc nous
sommes partis comme tout le monde dans
une veste et à l'ena avec la rage parce
que ce que je dois dire c'est que quand
j'ai vu mon père demandé pardon dans une
pharmacie pour acheter des comprimés et
qui n'a pas pu y aura ce comprimé on est
retourné à la maison je lui ai dit mon
arrière grand père a légué à ton grand
père les difficultés la mise est donc
grand p hallegatte on paie la misère des
diffultés la famille
ton père t'a relégué à toi toutes ces
souffrances moi tu m'a légué la famine
chasse comme évanouissent je ne la
verrai plus jamais le docteur des
enfants
voilà dix ans et cela a été le moteur de
ma vie je suis rentré l'ida je vous
épargne les détails je suis sorti comme
sous préfet je démissionnais et puis je
me suis j'étais à l'avant tu j'ai tout
abandonné j'étais le plus jeune sous
préfet de corte y voit un peu comme mon
frère mon lot le plus jeune du préfet je
trouve que c'est trop jeune pour une
fonction tout pour te coller je vais
partir là vendu à londres un peu partout
dans le monde glané les diplômes
je suis rentré dans une organisation
internationale et j'ai fait toute
l'afrique mais également tous beaucoup
de pays au monde beaucoup de pays en
tout cas tous les grands pays du monde
mais c'est un hasard
c'était pas la prochaine fois pas daisy
c'était l'émission qui me menait dans
ces pays pour apprendre pour exécuter
des missions et je travaille dans les
pays qui étaient totalement effondré au
congo congo également l'est de la rdc
totalement fond de rouvrir des gens se
tuent et mûri autour de vous la somalie
contre lens au parc à tous les bateaux
qui sont kystique et et qui était de
tous les parlers pyatt le somaliland qui
sont des étapes qui existent sur le
territoire avec l'espace du papier en
libye tous les pays pratiquement
l'afrique plus d'une quarantaine de pays
d'afrique
et quand vous revenez de la ku leuven
avec beaucoup d'amour et d'humanisme
vous n'avez plus la même personne parce
que tout le monde vous regarde plus le
monde comme tout le monde
tout ce qui est jaune pour tout le monde
vous parlez un peu vert parce que vous
voyez au delà il ya tellement des vies
tellement d'amour et c'est la mission
que nous nous donnons on ne travaille
pas au hasard
les missions sont des mission
sacerdotale salut des services de dieu
tout ce que vous faites vous êtes
photographe cameraman preneur de son
dans ces salles maintenant c'est une
mission de travail et en perfectionnant
et nos missions c'est la vie de tous les
jours quand on descend n'avait pas fonds
apporter de l'espoir quand vous serrez
une vieille femme d'un vin qu'albi de
toute sa vie à jamais salie une autorité
vous avez ajouté quelques jours david
est quelqu'un vous allez transformer ce
matin vous avez transformé sa relation
avec le service public et je me donne
trois exemples rapidement il a mis des
fous est ici
et donc moi le président de l'ami des
fous je suis allé donc dans ma mission
de contrôle de l'hôpital de castres où
j'habite
je suis allée à l'hôpital encore une
fois comme il le disait cette
perspective de classifier de catégoriser
et j'ai même écrit sur ma page est
actuellement pour ceux qui l'ont lu mon
témoignage obtient sa nouvelle ville
nous sommes tous des malades mentaux
rose ici et je vois des êtres humains
qui voit au delà je vois une petite
fille que je n'ai jamais vu de ma vie
qui me raconte ma vie en grande-bretagne
à hampton côtes et les marchés on lâche
était impeccable je vois une autre
petite fille qu'à 16 ans qui me dit
comment j'étais enfant de choeur dans
son village il ya de cela 40 ans je vois
quelqu'un d'autre qui me prédit mon avis
ni que j'ai pas dis ici parce que vous
connais des personnes que je n'ai jamais
vu de mon existence et qui sont capables
de parler de ma vie de moins ils n'ont
pas internet parce que c'est interdit
le soir docteur ya pas de ne pas accès à
tout cela mais comment vous faites parce
qu'il transcende la chaîne les
contingences physiquement actuelle il
voit au delà parce qu'ils ont de l'amour
pour l'autre l'amour qu'on ne leur donne
pas et qui l'a traumatisée au point de
les rendre malades et c'est ça la
puissance de l'amour du travail
travailler avec acharnement et j'ai vu
des médecins bien sûr qui traite des cas
désespérés mais qui sont contents de le
faire et l'image qui a été projeté de ce
grade stocks ont vite avec des choses
brillantes c'est ça avoir l'amour et
affronter ceux qui n'ont plus d'âme ou
des autres
c'est très important liège a vu facebook
un ami m'a appelé il m'a dit les
gardiens que je suis facebook super
héros dc c'est une jeune femme qui fait
un témoin une jeune femme qui a passé à
mon bureau et que j'ai rappelé parce que
je le fais à la liste de ceux qui sont
passés j'appelle le simple fait d'avoir
payé quelqu'un pour vous êtes passé à
mon bureau
de quoi s'agit-il elle est publiée sur
facebook jamais vu ça
et puis on vient me dirait 4500 light
les jeunes tapotant 700 commentaires
mais avec un mot fait de petite chose de
naturel qui est extraordinaire c'est
votre travail
c'est ce qu'on devrait être c'est ce
qu'on devrait faire
c'est ce qu'on dirait fait on peut faire
ça avec amour et on n'a toujours pas je
la dia dans une vidéo en août est
toujours tendue comparative et jouer les
gentils qui changera pas le monde
le monde change tout le temps regardez
j'ai un casque je parle vous m'entendez
il ya même peut-être un facebook deals à
quelques machines au népal les amis de
bachelet à 40 da nous voir depuis la
chine c'est l'invention
regardez comment ils la ilaha illa il a
détruit tous les obstacles tous ceux qui
sont là on change le monde c'est pas
vrai on peut avoir un monde qui a bien
qui est beau je suis allé dans une fois
ma mission une fois en australie où j'ai
travaillé pendant quelques temps et je
suis allée gta preuves et challes une
fois suis un marché est on avec un ami
on a choisi de produire des légumes qui
tâte bien ce matin au moment de payer je
demande on dit après il ya pas les
vendeurs croient pas les vendeurs non le
prix affiché
c'est en plein janvier de la plantation
y dépose vous déposer l'argent pour le
culot que le nombre des quelques abris
tout partait c'est l'amour l'amour la
confiance
le travail le respect de la foi de
l'autre un marché 122 verrez c'est ici
venez le cerveau produit allez vous
balader
de toute façon moi pis quand ça peut
arriver petit à bassam et c'est ça la
mission et tous les jours travailler
avec amour dont vous donnez nous parlons
aujourd'hui parce que nous essayons
d'échanger les expériences menées dans
mon émission du j'ai quelqu'un de la
sécurité que là on met les gens en
prison
pour votre sécurité on organise les
situations difficiles on prendre des
initiatives
on doit déguerpir des gens on doit
déplacer des familles on l'a fait des
nominations on doit écarter des gens
pour que la cité fonctionne bien cette
mission régalienne de l'état avec
laquelle on transige pas on s'amuse pas
ça passe ça vous va de sécurité quand
vous avez sorti de cette salle vous
allez prendre parti ou votre bac à
retourner à abidjan
mais vous savez tout le système c'est
culte qui a derrière on peut mettre que
vous n'y a aucune inquiétude
mais quand on filme ses missions
régaliennes de la mission humaine de
coeur de parle aux gens de la souris
2 le temps de la main je dis bonjour et
vous ne savez pas ce que ça apporte à
votre vie c'est très important d'avoir
cette fête toutes ces missions de vie et
vous pouvez tout fait dans votre vie
ouvert à tout l'argent si cet aspect
mais vous n'êtes absolument rien et là
je ne le comprennent pas pour courir
après l'argent tout le temps il avait
raison après la jalousie aiguille pour
ses amis sur facebook vous insulter les
gens que vous connaissez même pas un
délit mais vous vous trompez vous même
pas ces dérives au sein de nos secte ou
sections de la pseudo on peut tout
découvriez qu'est ce que vous avez fait
vous êtes parce que vous vous projetez
vos propres échecs sur vos amis pourquoi
lui et rihanna comment j'ai pas réussi
comme elle peut feuilleter nous avait
dit quoi cette ville est coupée
parce que vous n'avez pas fait ça vous
injuriez pour rien parce que vous n'avez
pas vous projeter votre chèque lui avait
dit qu'il croit il à quoi il vient d'où
et vous êtes là vous suivait souvent le
contre modèle on voit éparpillés sur
facebook
mais tout ce que vous faites et facebook
ça va vous l'attraper le gouverneur de
floride a dû démissionner parce qu'il ya
30 ans il a tenu des propos racistes et
il y à 50% des jeunes américains qui
sont admis à dette à des interviews mais
qui échoue on les recruteurs d'un moment
parce qu on a fouillé il était en train
de boire si facebook et demi de photos
partout en train de tenir des propos
mais faites attention
utilisez-la moyens et puis il ya le côté
spirituel
vous pensez que la vie est gratuite
comme pas 3 ar que vous êtes tellement
fort tellement intelligent que dieu dieu
n'est pas dans votre vie mais tout ce
que vous faites c'est la classe ya
quelque chose qui a reçu du matériel qui
est invisible
c'est ça qui vous dit ne pensez pas m tu
me fatigues va là bas je n'ai pas envie
d'en placer des mots des injures
gratuites mais c'est ça un masque si
votre corps qui se déplace et vous
comprenez pas que ce qu'on veut des
choux ou ne comprenais pas mais c'est ça
vous avez accumulé cette négativité
c'est un nuage dont un nouveau record
soit qu'elle pouvait pas avancer
oubliez ça chacun a sa chance
libéré va libérer votre esprit libéré
tous ceux qui vous changent de la
négativité qui nous empêchent d'avancer
dans l'aude ya de l'amour de la force de
la foi
regardez ce qu'il ya de l'autre regardez
ce que l'on peut donner
si vous ne pouvez pas aider
ne déshonorez pas le petit qui demande
l'argent de la rue sauval devrait
ignorer le ne jouiez pas ne frappait pas
donc invité les jeunes invités de
sombrer dans dans la résignation
on ne peut pas faire payer la bizarrerie
la bise à quelqu'un qui a été votre
heure qui s en est fallu de fait et la
trace encore là malheureusement que les
femmes qui peuvent voir trace comprenez
et vous vous allez dire celui-là qu'il
n'y a plus d'espoir pour une vie non
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai ne sombrez
pas dans la facilité
laissez les autres par les laisser les
autres s'agite et laisser les autres dit
des choses qui sont un passement vrai il
y a des difficultés c'est vrai mais voit
détermination a réussi sera toujours
premier devant n'importe quelle
difficulté la vie regardez ce qui vous
en parler regardez les neuf qui vous en
parlait il ya de la vie sa part de
relier regarder les drames qui sont
arrivés jeux présents par exemple les
drame affectif familiaux des drames
biologique
regardez tous ceux qui ont parlé comment
ils sont arrivés à surpasser tout ce
qu'il appelle destiné à jouer et c'est
ce qu'on vous demande nous sommes là
pour ça j'en parle on parle de nous en
tant qu'individu si la poêlée de nous et
tout les épaulettes avec les étoiles
partout nous sommes venus parler de
nourrir notre amour de notre vie et de
vous parce que ce pays c'est vous devez
vous qui sur le président le premier
ministre et ministre des jets les
créateurs les docteurs ingénieurs les
artistes les digues et très célèbre
c'est vous ça votre vie donc n'en
doutent pas du tout et le philosophe
disait liens de grand ne peut se faire
sans passion violente et la raison
elle-même les industries donc les
passions dans leurs comptes comme autant
de ressort de notre existence
soyez passionné vivent une vie saine
aller toujours plus haut
parce que vous êtes fort fonte
il sans jamais vous arrêter et je répète
les anglais lui dise de sky ezio limites
mais si beaucoup
[Applaudissements]